to tell the story of Gwyn's children is
to tell the story of Gwyn himself for
his children were all born to fulfill a
purpose
Gwyn's verse daughter gwynevere was a
maternal figure cherished by all she was
born to soothe the kingdom after a
period of intense war against the
Dragons Gwyn sun gwyndolin was a master
of illusion after Guinevere fled the
failing kingdom in fear
it was Gwendolyn who disguised the
fading of the light and finally Gwen's
youngest daughter Fillion nor was truly
a product of her father's pride before
as long as she slumbered Gwynn's world
would not end but there was a fourth
child a nameless King erased from
history the God of War
Gwyn's firstborn son the first war ever
fought was the war for disparity a war
for the right to flesh and blood where
before there was only stone a war for
the right to the surface where before
there was only the below a war for the
right to a beginning and to an end for
before there was neither the everlasting
dragons were to be introduced to the
concept of the end and it was Gwynn's
firstborn son like his brothers and his
sisters to come who was divinely
conceived for this purpose so it was
that the sons eldest born inherited the
lightning from his father along with
this powerful predisposition for war and
arms his weapon was an ingenious sword
spear that leveraged the user's own
bodyweight allowing it to be trodden
remarkably deep into tough dragonhide
this was the earliest form of what would
become the cross spear which went on to
inspire the legendary weapon wielded by
the Dragonslayer Ornstein who was
unsurprisingly
anointed the first Knight to the
nameless king himself the nameless king
also wore an attire woven of sharp
dragon scales as they were themselves
impervious to fire and it seems that the
best tools against the drag
were taken from the Dragons themselves a
philosophy that another legendary figure
Havel clearly took to heart as the man
cased himself in stone and took a
legendary dragon tooth as his weapon
Havel - not only served the nameless
King in the war but also his first night
Ornstein as well becoming the third
member of a legendary trio of Dragon
Slayers
who would eventually come to inspire the
miraculous tale known as sacred oath and
so it was with strength courage cunning
and unity that the war for disparity was
one dragon shall never be forgotten
we Knights fought valiantly but every
one of them
we lost speech spawn of an acceleration
fry hatred rage the Dragons cheese dog
dearest emojis novel understand one day
me this very little to be said who who
does a dog know has to hunt but I'm
lucky to be alive I suppose with the war
one these Lords were the first to face
an uncomfortable truth that their glory
much like that of the Dragons would not
last forever the everlasting dragons
were vulnerable now and were forced to
adapt to this unfamiliar and hostile
world so they gave birth and slowly
began to mutate and deviate in their
evolution wyverns serpents man serpents
and basilisks the imperfect the
crossbreeds and the wretches dragons
that spit fire lightning poison and
corrosion some even caught the undead
curse
and so it was that despite Guin's best
efforts dragons and their kin lived on
some as unchanged as ever rumor it may
be but I have heard of a surviving
ancient dragon who resides in this land
a coterie of undead serves the dragon as
they trained to become dragons
themselves sounds unlikely but you never
know deal as the gods really should have
known faith always finds a way and
ironically it was the gods and not the
Dragons who failed to adapt a war had
been fought in the name of disparity but
Gwynn's age of fire was nothing of the
sort
darkness was the enemy now and Gwyn
would do anything to prevent his age of
fire from ending anything so how
righteous truly could their war against
the ancient unchanging dragons have been
when Gwyn himself refused to cede to the
natural order thus began the betrayal of
Gwynn's firstborn son he is God of War
who allied with the remaining ancient
dragons ashamed by his first Born's
betrayal enraged at his disobedience and
driven by that famous desire to erase
all that opposed him Gwyn disowned his
firstborn son his royal blood was denied
his legacy was expunged from the annals
of history and the altars of his worship
were smashed beyond recognition
his name was lost forever but as the
gods oughta know faith always finds a
way and the nameless King had some
faithful knights indeed look within the
rubble of these statues look amidst the
traces of the nameless Kings foot
wrappings his braces his attire and he
might just spy a familiar cross spear
design belonging to the firstborns first
Knight the Dragonslayer Ornstein
in the dragon Lesage that followed the
nameless king's betrayal Ornstein was a
science to guard the grand cathedral and
for the captain of the four Knights of
Gwyn this must have been a lowly role
indeed as he wasn't even guarding
Gwynn's daughter he was guarding an
illusion nor was he alongside his fellow
Knights instead he was partnered with
executioner smo a cannibal and a glutton
someone who could never call himself
Ornstein sequel so as his fellow Knights
faded away as Gwyn burned to cinder for
his age on Stein eventually left the
ruined Cathedral and abandoned his post
in order to search for the nameless king
that he once served funnily enough smo
of all people was the last night of Gwyn
to remain at his post we know this for
after defeating Aldrich we can purchase
his armor which implies that smo the
cannibal may well have been cannibalized
himself an ironic twist of fate that
ornstein was lucky to avoid and we don't
know exactly where or for how long
Ornstein set off in search of his
nameless king but if one attempted to
trace his path one would find evidence
of the influence that these two men may
well have left upon the world in fur OSA
for example we witness an order of lion
Knights with Armour blessed by a certain
war God even more curiously the figure
depicted on their helmet stands his own
against a dragon in the Drowned ruins of
hate there's a being who aspires to the
great legacy of the old Dragon Slayer so
is this on Stein himself probably not
though how curious is it that a man
inspired by a dragon slayer would be
allied with the dragons that are right
outside his gate the world was changing
and in truth those who aspire to conquer
dragons overwhelmingly end up with them
their allies look to our nameless king
who was born for a war against them only
to ally with the vestee jizz of their
race
look to vendrick who inherited Quinn's
legacy yet aspired to recreate their
power look to the kingdom of larak whose
Knights were originally hunters of
dragons yet they ended up taming them
and fighting at their side look at
Prince Ricard who fought in a stronghold
filled with serpents and ended up being
summoned as their champion at arch
dragon peak looked to Havel who adopted
a spine of stone and a dragon's tooth
only to uphold a sacred oath with their
nameless King and finally looked to
Ornstein the Dragon Slayer who laden
with duties and oaths decided that the
only one that would matter was his
pledge to Gwynn's exiled son and so it
was that the way of the Dragon led him
to the nameless Kings stronghold in the
years after his exile the nameless King
had tamed a storm Drake upon which he
had led a lifetime of battle eventually
he settled here upon an arch dragon peak
this it appears was a place where
dragons and their kin could worship and
live in peace it was only a matter of
time after all until Gwynn's age of fire
would burn down to ash and Dragons as we
know have both time and patience in
abundance
alas a nun kindled would eventually find
his way here to arch Dragon Peak driven
by this unstoppable desire to claim the
strength of a war God and to claim the
strength of his ancient companions
so that Gwynn's age of fire could
finally be brought to an end for war is
supposed to be waged for what we believe
in not to erase our opposition from
existence
you